Tout d'abord, c'est épique en termes d'échelle et
deuxièmement, l'histoire de Moïse était un
défi énorme que j'ai vraiment adoré. Je voulais
explorer la complexité de son
personnage et j'ai été abasourdi par l'
histoire de la vie du géant et par ce qu'il a vécu en
pensant qu'ils étaient frères,
puis  Les rivaux, puis plus tard, se font la guerre,
cela peut être très
intéressant. Le processus de
création de ce film est vraiment difficile,
c'est une production immense, tout est
aussi grand que nous pouvons construire, mais en même
temps, Ridley a de plus grandes idées.
Attention, ce qui m'a attiré dans ce matériel,
c'est qu'il y a une beauté dans une
compétence massive, vous travaillez avec au moins 700
membres d'équipage plus les 4 000 extras et bien sûr,
l'armée sera élargie de façon exponentielle,
4 000 seront en mosaïque et grandiront en
20 000, c'est assez élaboré.  c'est le plus grand
film que j'ai jamais fait, assez incroyable, je
suis venu vous dire que quelque chose
arrive qui échappe à mon
contrôle